Понад 400 мільйонів тонн сміття -
як промислового, так і побутового, щороку з’являється у Німеччині.
У перерахунку на кожного жителя країни це приблизно 500 кілограмів.
За даними німецької статистики, з цієї пів тонни сміття чверть
- це органічні відходи, ще стільки ж - папір, картон і скло,
30 кілограмів - громіздкі речі на кшталт старих меблів,
холодильників та іншої побутової техніки.
Решта 220 кілограмів - це залишкові відходи, більша частина яких -
будівельне сміття: бита цегла, уламки штукатурки, гіпсокартону та плитки.
Система збору та утилізації сміття у Німеччині добре налагоджена,
так само як і система штрафів за неправильне поводження з відходами.
У кожній федеральній землі - свої особливості та розміри штрафів.
Приміром, у найбільшій за населенням землі Північний Рейн-Вестфалія
за викинуту не в смітник шкірку банана або упаковку від бургера
стягується штраф від 10 до 25 євро. А місцева влада окремих міст
зробила ці штрафи ще суворішими. Так, у Вупперталі можуть оштрафувати і до 100 євро.
У Кельні за недопалок, викинутий у недозволеному місці, стягнуть 50 євро.
Якщо ж це зробили на дитячому майданчику або в парку, то й 150 євро.
У деяких містах штрафують одразу ж на місці і вимагають сплатити готівкою або карткою.
Якщо порушника спіймали вперше, іноді спочатку зроблять попередження.
За розкидані в лісі пляшки, упаковку та інші "дрібні" відходи, приміром,
після пікніку, можна отримати штраф до 80 євро,
а викинуті в недозволеному місці банки з залишками лаку чи фарби
коштуватимуть порушнику 25-80 євро залежно від обсягу.
Якщо ж до складу фарби входять синтетичні компоненти,
які забруднюють довкілля і які потрібно утилізувати в особливих умовах,
то сума штрафу значно зростає.
До речі, у Німеччині є так звані "сміттєві" детективи.
Вони аналізують викинуте в неналежному місці сміття і вираховують порушника.
Важливою є будь-яка дрібниця. Особливо допоміжними можуть стати
клаптики кореспонденції чи якогось документа в смітті.
Також "сміттєві" детективи шукають свідків, аналізують відео з камер спостереження
і навіть влаштовують засідки, щоб спіймати порушника на гарячому,
коли в якомусь місці смітять регулярно і дуже зухвало.
Просто взяти і викинути великогабаритне сміття,
старий матрац чи меблі у Німеччині не можна.
За це вам випишуть штраф. У Кельні, наприклад,
один-єдиний старий стілець, який ви виставили навіть поруч
зі звичайним сміттєвим контейнером, коштуватиме 50 євро,
а за викинутий таким чином кухонний гарнітур
доведеться заплатити штраф від 400 до 1500 євро. Але не все так страшно.
Подібне сміття забирають у Кельні, як і майже в усіх німецьких містах, безкоштовно.
Потрібно тільки оформити відповідне замовлення по телефону або в інтернеті.
Замовник відзначає, що саме буде викидати,
і до 7 години ранку в призначений день або напередодні
виставляє все це перед будинком. У жодному разі не раніше,
адже сміттєвози не їздять містом щодня у пошуках великогабаритного сміття,
тож вам можуть вліпити штраф.
У сусідньому Бонні дещо інша система.
Там замовляти вивезення громіздкого сміття не потрібно.
У колишній столиці Німеччини вивозять його чотири рази на рік у певні дні,
і в ці дні кожен може виставити непотрібні йому речі на вулицю. І це безкоштовно.
А от у Кельні можливий безкоштовний обсяг -
три кубометри такого сміття на родину за одне вивезення.
У Берліні ж за кожне замовлення доведеться сплатити
залежно від кількості та розмірів сміття мінімум 50 євро.
Водночас є і спеціальні пункти прийому таких відходів.
Для приватних осіб і не у промислових обсягах це нічого не коштує.
Регіони і муніципалітети самі визначають правила на своїй території.
Електроприлади можна здати безкоштовно в спеціальному приймальному пункті,
а також у деяких магазинах: дрібну побутову техніку - безкоштовно,
а якщо мова йде про великі холодильники або пральні машини,
то в обмін на придбання нового товару.
Спроба ж викинути холодильник десь у лісі коштує від 100 до 300 євро,
а якщо пристрій містить небезпечні речовини, то і до двох з половиною тисяч євро.
Тому, хто нехтує правилами і викидає автомобільні шини неналежним чином, -
штраф від 80 до 200 євро, і це якщо шин - до п'яти штук.
За більшу кількість накладається вже штраф до 510 євро.
Зламаний велосипед, викинутий у недозволеному місці,
буде коштувати його колишньому власнику від 20 до 80 євро,
а розбитий мотоцикл - від 50 до 200 євро.
За великий автобрухт, кинутий напризволяще,
передбачено штраф від ста до півтори тисячі євро.
За багаторазове порушення закону або, наприклад, за вивезення декількох машин,
порушнику доведеться сплатити вже до п’яти тисяч євро.
Будівельне сміття можна здати в пункті прийому вторсировини за певну плату.
Також є і платні служби вивозу. А от якщо впіймали на гарячому,
коли викидали старий ламінат, плитку, цеглу або інше будівельне сміття
об'ємом до 1 кубометра, доведеться сплатити штраф у розмірі від 100 до 410 євро.
За більший обсяг стягується вже до 5 тисяч євро.
У малоквартирних будинках та в сільській місцевості
для рослинних відходів є спеціальні контейнери,
але якщо "зеленого" органічного сміття багато,
то краще відвести його в комунальний пункт збору.
За несанкціоновану утилізацію натомість загрожує
штраф до 820 євро залежно від обсягу.